yeah he's on the phone with you guys
he's like I don't know three grand and
then smacks
like and they're like sure and then and
like we hang up we're like [__]
suckers you're like [__]
you welcome to careful boys I mean what
do you what do you guys want to say holy
[__] Extreme Makeover JK news Edition
just happened hit my office
Ry is the exhibit of JK news dude he's
the West Coast Custom yeah he's like
what do you guys like exhibit fish look
at the shark in her
closet you like barbecue I made a grill
in the toilet for you I heard you like
grandfather
clocks accurate this is insane I can't
believe certifiably insane it doesn't
make sense Honestly though thanks for
trusting me to even do it like thanks
for trusting me to to not look at it and
then just come back into it credit to
Bart and Joe
mostly I trust you more than I trust
myself we've seen what you've done with
your set business so we know what you're
capable of and then you even like you
know when you do things like the homie
way uh you even made it more
professional with even like the
handdrawn sketches so I was like oh [__]
this is this was like rolling out
Blueprints and [__] I'm like this is
tight it looked pretty ghetto but at
least it gives you an idea I thought it
was legit what if we came in here though
after you'd given all those plans and
[__] and then we come in here you just
did crayons all over the
walls Dre and we're like oh wow Ryan wow
it looks great I just put Ikea [__]
everywhere it's the actual sketches but
right here this bigger Yeah man cuz you
guys didn't even check you just were
like once it was done you're like oh
cool and then you walked into it and
that's it yeah and then uh we had to
shoot some stuff for barbell and I knew
you guys were working here so I texted
you I was hey Ryan uh will you guys be
working there or did you want me to like
uh can I peek see what it looks like and
like just film your reaction I was okay
and I remember coming in I'm like I
wonder what look looks like now then
when I walked in I was like what the
[__] okay now I'm inside
waa holy [__] that [__] was crazy I
remember you were asking me like whose
Porsche is this so I had to look in the
the the security cameras Oh yeah and
then I was like oh [__] there's like AIS
and smack and everyone moving things in
in and out of the office and I'm like oh
this is
exciting whose Porsche is it I want know
it's a neighbor's Porsche it was a
neighbor guy neighbor's Porsche but I
was like damn dude that that was the
moment when I was like I'm [__] so
excited I want to see you guys right now
yeah cuz you can see us moving big ass
[__] in and out of the doors yeah and I
texted Joel I was like if we're passing
out bonuses this year Ryan gets at least
two times more than Anthony she gets all
of our bonuses give her my bonus dude
can we actually just split Anthony's
morus
too no can we P penalize Anthony he's
getting fine let's talk
him for Always Going On A Car Lot
promotions we should put a [__]
parking meter here and only Anthony has
to pay to park every
time his name on it keep giving him
tickets quar it every single time every
hour he to feed it yeah I pay a guy to
go put a ticket on his windshield every
[__]
put a boot on it tell him to park right
there where the the lines are and then
call Ron's Towing
Company no but thanks for like that's a
lot of trust man to just be like yeah do
your thing you act like you're a sketchy
[__] dude you're you're track
record appr this place is pretty sacred
man it's it would be hard to to depend
on somebody to do it justice man if it's
anybody that's going to be
Ryan but me and Nick were talking like
while you guys were filming stuff and I
we were kind of just like dude this is
so cool that we don't deserve this and
something bad's going to happen
something bad's going to happen all
going to get fired everything's going to
too good to be true yeah everything's
going to get blowed up now I remember
the first time we upgraded from this
office to Downtown LA and then me and
bar were like man you know we got to do
something big and like professional and
and awesome for the fans and then we're
like let's let's hire like a real TV
like movie set maker and then we did it
and it was something so [__] off
because we told them all the elements of
what we wanted and then it just didn't
match and I was like man why did this
just suck so bad and it was like oh no
one can replicate like the magic of
someone in your crew making something
right so like when this first office was
made it was really like made with the
group that was here and there was so
many little details and elements that
you had to know as the audience and the
inside you know jokes and everything so
I feel like like that was just missing
so much cuz it looked good like the the
outline was fine but like all the things
were just weird right and then
afterwards I think it just put us off
from like getting a pro to like do it
for us cuz every time we talked about
redoing the office it was like man we
want to clean this up but like who's
going to do it and like who can do it
dope and then we're like hm and
Anthony's like yeah let me do it
exactly zero deliver he always promises
never delivers never dude he pays he
pays hard when he's not here
man would you guys say that he kind of
like sparked the idea to maybe we should
do something with the office but he
didn't give the
specifics Shing him
off but I did I did look up a video I
went back and found and watched a video
of when you had first moved in here oh
when we're painting ourselves and stuff
yeah just to see just to like it's been
over 12 years just to get the feeling of
that because and then it was like it was
kind of nice to see that cuz I'm like oh
man like in the beginning like all
everybody really did like care a lot
when they made all the things it was fun
I'm like I want to have that same
feeling like what I'm doing it like
excited to show you guys [__] excited
for you to discover like little like
Easter eggs and stuff shout outs to
smack too cuz she's not even invested in
this place she's the best she has
nothing to do with she doesn't like our
videos she told me she doesn't even
watch them she turns them off she heart
and soul into this place too that's so
[__] cool of it yeah she was with me
every day every day that we were here
and she did all this she she painted Mo
all the wall paint was her like most of
it yeah cuz now feel like I owe her like
if you guys need to like relon your
house I need to go relon or rucko or
some [__] I owe her now yeah like she
she she did this post you know on her on
her Instagram where she was like taking
a picture of like the bathroom mirror
like doing like some paint cleaning and
she goes amount of hours of this and I
was like I know that [__] bathroom
you spent that many hours I went in I
was like I thank you so freaking much
and then her response was more like I
love doing this [__] it was a favor to
me it was like what she's like [__] you
you're toxic in all
caps yeah she really does love it I mean
that's I mean cuz also it helps us cuz
we have our business too where we we do
set design we do installations so you
can use this as an example yeah if you
see this crazy [__] where where can they
see or
it's called retro cetra and it's on IG
retro cetra if you want a cool podcast
room just a dope ass interior retro
cetra yeah but then also it's our it's
our way of like you know kind of
strengthening our relationship it
actually helps us when we get to work
together and do things otherwise we're
just always separate doing different
things you guys don't fight all the time
I mean we might a little bit but I think
overall it like it helps us bonding
through work yeah yeah yeah bonding
through work really dude when I came the
other day and you were like you know
where my keys are and you guys you just
seeing you guys finding your keys was
like the funniest thing you're like oh I
think I left it over here and she's like
no wait and then it ended up being in
her pockets and I was like oh dude you
guys and I was like you dumb [__] dumb
[__] that's right that's my dog [__]
[__] how many guys you [__] before
me he made your brain rot I know yeah no
she she really does love it like [__]
body count that's really her thing and
just getting like it helps us improve
skills it helps us like you know execute
ideas that like like even just that was
my dream to to mount that yeah I just
I've never seen that and I that sick do
something like we don't deserve any of
this [__] no we don't you know what's
crazy even the carpets I was like these
carpets are great they're great I could
lay on them I was texting Bart the other
day and I was like dude this is so
[__] amazing he's like I know man and
I was like you know this is what happens
when a high performer loves your
company it's like it's like we've been
been through so many peoples right and
like a lot of people they talk but they
want somebody else to [__] do it yeah
ideas guys are great though you got to
have them you got to have them really
helpful yeah they'll start it start
let's have some meetings let's talk
about it but I think that's what that's
what this is now like this era is like
everybody's this is a downest group
exactly I think that's the difference is
like we have six folks including seventh
can in the layer back there remember
right
here and Anthony and LA right
now anon's at another carlot grand
opening yeah yeah but I think the this
is actually a completely different feel
cuz everyone's kind of like a leader in
their own yeah field coming together but
it's completely different cuz before JK
was like that was the main fulltime for
everyone right and then so everyone's
hitting it hard that way but then when
everyone has something better and bigger
to do but you make it an effort to just
come here out of your way and then
create awesomeness it's like damn dude
this is what what it looks like when all
these leaders get together to do
something it's freaking awesome it's
like all bosses yeah it's dope without
the the too many cooks in the kitchen
issue well that's the thing cuz we you
know who to give the control to so it
can get done yeah true cuz they say good
leaders are good followers right but I'm
always following so I don't know I
always no I think that's what's awesome
is like when it comes time to like who
does what we just like relinquish it and
let them do it and we just support for
every that we do we ride we all just
ride in our own ways that's why I
appreciate it it's like you guys were
were cool enough to be like okay you got
this and then that makes doing it even
easier I think micromanaging actually
hurts it cuz it's almost like oh here
here's your freedom but then do it my
way freely
right people of their motivations yeah
and it's like what the [__] I thought
you wanted me to do this I'm actually so
cool if you want to do this at my
house yeah man what if I just make your
house look exactly like this this is all
you're capable of doing just this over
Pony of the wall different variations of
this over and over just check your walls
you'll never leave this room well plus I
got to say dude just having this and
being able to like lay on a couch that
doesn't suck that couch is so nice y
this is amazing without the vinyl
peeling we can actually take naps over
without inhaling the vinyl dude that
vinyl was peeling it felt like I had
seaweed all over my body oh you want to
know something funny so those old
couches right I I stacked them outside
by the dumpster and I I put a a listing
that they were free yeah I think like
two or three people came and and didn't
want them holy
[__] it was that bad like some guy some
guy I saw a guy loading it on his truck
both of them and then uh me and smack
went over there and we were like Hey
we're the ones who put the couches out
thanks for taking him like uh and he was
like yeah they're cool and he strapped
them in and then we drove away and then
we saw him unloading him
again he probably tried him out he's
like why are they thanking me for taking
why did he go through all the trouble he
was ratcheting him down and then and
then started unloading him that's so
funny he just got in the car and said I
got seaweed up man he's like I'm itchy
now like there's so many colors of paint
in here did you have just buckets of
paint or you went out and bought like
every color well yeah the well we get
the primaries and then what smack does
is she mixes them so the like when
there's when you see like a version of
green it's it's just they're mixed so
these so she just has one green and she
made all these other greens so what we
do is we buy we buy oops paint so like
that's the biggest hack is you go to
Home Depot you go to all the Home Depot
you go to their rack where they make
mistakes or they have return so what
would normally be like a $50 can is n
bucks wow yeah for a gallon and then you
just you just get all the colors you can
get and then and then you just mix them
Ryan's a genius you get insane savings I
never even thought about mixing any of
these things see we only know how to
spend a lot of [__] money foolishly I
didn't know you could do that you could
mix paint like that yo yeah dude you
ever painted something billionaires hate
this sometimes there's some really good
quality paint that they cuz if they make
a if they make a color mistake or if
people return paint and they're like oh
it's the wrong color they just put it on
the rack and it's brand new yeah you go
in the morning and the wreck is stacked
dude wow and you just like travel with
different ones we went to the alham one
you know how to have fun with like your
work yeah we freaking love it man it's
like a it's a high dude and it also it
honestly does like make us closer so I
enjoy it yeah did you guys have sex in
here yeah that's why he didn't want help
from him I was like hey dude just let me
know I'll come down and help and then
he's all like like nah I'mma work with
smack head I'm going to work with smack
you guys are making memories in here
what you guys do on that couch he's on
primary
colors all this drywalling is making you
hot huh I oopsi in the paint again
that's how you mix the paint oh I
recognize that color SE
white it's chunky [__] Ryan cream
right there everything everything wall
right there everything in here is done
at a drastic amount of savings like some
of these big things like even this large
these large wooden things they're from
like recycle centers no way all this
stuff is like free you can just take it
from a
recycling what what do you mean like
they just have platforms or they're raw
pieces of wood you put it together
material recycling but don't they need
it for recycling or they just give it to
you that is the recycling so you're
reusing it right different sets after
they're done filming it's cheaper for
them to take it to a set recycling than
it is to
where the [__] is a set recycling at
Water Village so yeah you just go to
these places and they'll just like you
can reuse whole like giant set pieces
different things wow bro Ryan skill set
is so crazy doing that is like way more
cost effective than like actually buying
a shitload like like Wood's expensive I
think you blew my brains more than any
teacher ever has seriously can you like
make a YouTube channel just explaining
like all the [__] that you do dude
that's so it's pretty that takes the fun
out of it man that's how that's how this
able to be done in like 3K there's no
way like like a guy the guy that we
didn't know would charges like 50k or
yeah for sure I was telling Joe I was
like dude this looks like at least 20
G's or 30 G's if you got it
professionally done it's actually legit
3K and that's just materials I bet you
he only spent two and he pocketed one
what the [__] smart guy I told you he's
CRA brain big brain smart I started
having like bigger jewelry and like
grills and [__] for 1K Ryan's got a
Porsche wait and he's like you can get
the Porsche at the co-op you just go to
the co-op they give them away on Fridays
every other Friday but it's like 1K
more yeah everything's done in a massive
savings so you know and it's all just
like if you look really closely it's
just like little DIY crafty stuff made
of like normal things man you have a
[__] gift dude you do you know what's
awesome though it it just feels like
right when I thought that it would be
our last year something new happens and
it's like well here's another year for
us a brand new office it just feels like
all right well we have to keep making
content now what a waste you know Ryan
did all this
2024 here we go 17th year for us let's
do it we're a whole High School senior
who did this the careful boys logo with
the oh I got that made on Etsy yeah
there's like a there's like a sale for
like cuz there's so many competitors for
the these Neon Signs Now there's like
the prices gone down a lot yeah those
used to be like hundreds of bucks but is
it a real neon side or is it led they're
all LED now yeah like nobody needs real
neon's not cost effective and it if it
breaks you're screwed so that's just
better it's just an LED line that's just
like nicely uh curved I like that you
got this man it sa that was an amazing
find that was just from some lady in
elel that like how did you even fit that
I've been trying to find a shelf that
had a curve to it like that so that we
wouldn't walk into it and that way
there's more room for Nick on that side
so you were like looking on like offer
up or something that's just secondhand
yeah it can do like 44% more physical
comedy now I just it's my thing dude
check all this space yeah that that
shelf was like $40 and it was like yeah
you make me want to sell everything and
start from scratch
on yeah dude if the timing's right I
mean but then I was shopping for thing
like you guys remember when I first
bought that uh that bar with the thing
that was like a year ago oh and you just
had it store I've just stored a lot of
things over time a lot of this shit's
like my [__] from like way back and it
uh just rep Pur I think that if we had a
vision already and wanted you to execute
like a specific look then it would be
harder to be like budget friendly cuz
then you have to look for those pieces
but then if you had the free-for-all too
you can be like all right I just find
what works yeah that helps to be able to
see it and then just keep it for a while
until you need it I I like how you just
repurposed a ton of [__] that we already
had too yeah and a lot and then charged
them for it and then bought a
Porsche big brain [__] so smart
dude Carrera dealers love this trick so
far I just hear that he bought paint and
a really cheap
[__] that was under a 100 bucks yeah
he like and he went to Kingo and just
printed out all of these pieces of bar
yeah he's on the phone with you guys
he's like I don't know three grand and
then smacks
like and they like sure and and then
smack
like we hang up we're like [__]
suckers
bro you're like [__]
you yeah like even even that arcade
machine that's from my old Studio it
actually does work oh really what kind
of game is in there everything that's in
here women games but then but then we I
just thought it'd be a nice piece
repainted it put that little like
believe all women on it is that on the
on this side of the screen or behind it
it's just a print out and then I just
like put it on there everything
everything's like uh dude that museum
looking Bart and Joe the uncle that's my
favorite thing like to see that is like
so freaking sural that's your history
right there your legacy that you were
able to do that it's just crazy it looks
so cool when I walked in the office it
was it was beyond anything I imagined I
love seeing that thing I had like I knew
it was going to be sick I knew like Ryan
was going to blow us away but when I
walked in I was like this is incredible
I was blown away just by that part I
know I was though I was like yo this is
sick he was like wa I'm like dude they
outside yeah let me process it in my own
way did you cry maybe did you cry I've
been really emotional these past couple
days I don't know
maybe no but no it is really [__]
cool to be able to walk in here and be
like oh my God Ryan spent so much time
and effort into this [__] place and
obviously the [__] that you guys built
too but it's like we have a [__] real
ass set like this is crazy I think the
best part of it all is that it was done
by a careful boy so he knew all the
details and all the jokes and he knew
all like what the fans you know said
about us and joking and everything and
it's just he put all of those elements
together plus the history of JK I just
wish there was more pictures of Jason
chenny holding all my bits everywhere
that'll be good maybe he can hold um the
woo price in the
Coogi and yeah in the fure that' be nice
touch maybe we'll figure out how to do
that I like that there's still a lot of
room for adding on more things yeah yeah
there's this the base there's lots of
room for more stuff so as even as we go
and make new jokes like
I love the fact that now they can appear
and the audience can be like I remember
when we first did that you know you make
me want to move back to LA so you could
design my
[Laughter]
house I know that now we're not going to
move to Vegas huh [__] no you're not no
this would imagine how cheap this would
be to do in Vegas that's true
$500 we'll just go to sign
graveyard yeah it's very
inspiring
he